the US national security adviser and his
Russian counterpart have held more than
five hours of talks in Geneva but john
bolton didn't give much away to
reporters at a short news briefing
afterwards I think we made a lot of
progress we identified certain areas
where lines of communication could be
restored there were some where the areas
of disagreement remained we didn't see
much utility and in resuming discussion
there are going to be some things where
we're going to consider inside the
United States government
consider more fully what our position is
and then decide to proceed from there
well this meeting of national security
advisors was while the groundwork was
laid for it when the presidents met in
Helsinki last month
today they covered the whole range of
pretty much what had been touched upon
in Helsinki they talked about nuclear
non-proliferation they talked about
cyberattacks they talked about the
situation in Syria in Afghanistan and in
Ukraine as well this meeting of course
comes when relations between Moscow and
Washington are a particularly low air
with sanctions from the United States
against Russia looming over the
poisoning of Sergius crippled in the
United Kingdom earlier this year
Russia denies any rare role in the
attempt on mr. Scalli files life when it
came to the Iranian sanctions in the
Iran nuclear deal John Bolton
unequivocal he was saying that the will
be sanctions put in place against Iran
and those doing business with Iran and
that the sanctions are coming in
November
he's aired it's the Russian side didn't
ask for any exemptions during the
meeting today and that the US side
aren't expecting to give many exemptions
at all they also talked about Iranian
troops in Syria mr. Bolton saying that
he wanted to see both as he put it
regular and irregular Iranian troops
removed from Syria pulled back from
Syria the Russian side going into this
had already said that they were in
support of this but that this wasn't
something that was going to be happening
immediately as with any of the
these meetings when it comes to senior
figures within the the Trump White House
and within the Trump the Trump
administration there were questions
about Russian meddling and this squirt
this time well it was no different
whether you ever concerned that your own
president is a security risk of course
not I mean that's a silly question
and I just spoke to him literally a few
minutes ago and we we have performed
here in exactly the way I think the two
leaders would have expected us to and
you know honestly have a little faith in
the American people who elected him
president thank you very much
we waited hours and hours for mr. Bolton
to come then and speak to us it was very
short not so sweet at the end there
following that question from my
colleague from the BBC it's worth noting
that after that one of mr. Bolton's
staff came along pulled her to one site
and told her that well her question was
ridiculous and that they wouldn't be
working with their organization in the
future that shocked quite a few of the
geneva diplomatic press corps here but
this meeting between the two national
security advisors it it didn't result in
any major breakthroughs we weren't
really expecting that but where they
agreed they still agree and where
there's disagreement well they're
certainly still discord between
Washington and Moscow as it stands at
the moment we get live reaction now from
former US congressman dr. Ron Paul
welcome to the program now john bolton
there was pretty tight-lipped after the
meeting but what were you able to read
into about how the meeting went with
what he did put forward well i i thought
it was terrible all he did was threaten
people and assume that we control the
world and we control everything one
thing that caught my my attention was
getting rid of get getting Iran to take
out their troops now that's a reasonable
request as long as the request is any
foreign nation that has troops in Syria
that have been uninvited should all
leave together that's what the problem
is this picking and choosing that we
decide and say yes he can have true
in here not the other ones but no I
think the threats and intimidation and
the sanctions it's just a penalty on the
people they never hurt the government
they just give incentives to the
government so I think I think this whole
notion that sanctions are a weapon and
now we as a country Americans oh yeah
you know threatening even more severe
sanctions and I think that's the wrong
way to go I think sanctions are an early
rehearsal for war continuing with what
you mentioned about Iran he said that
the two had discussed a variety of ways
for Iran forces to leave Syria what
might that mean well I have I no idea
but they're always negotiating deals and
negotiations but III think my position
strictly is that the only way I can see
it logically from a libertarian position
is that people who aren't invited into a
country shouldn't be there so anybody
that's there that has not been invited
so if somebody asks me opinion or if I
were in government I would just say the
people ought to leave and if it were my
own government which it is right now my
advice have been for a long time don't
go in and leave and leave as soon as you
can because it doesn't help anything and
and it just leads to more trouble and it
prolongs the war I mean look how long
we've been in Afghanistan because of a
similar situation so I have no idea what
he's talking about
working a deal with with the Russians on
how to handle and the Iranians but this
whole thing that we have said that we're
our goal our stated position now I
stayed by Bolton beside me and and just
by the way Bolton doesn't speak for all
the American people he speaks for the
neo and neoconservatives but the policy
now is the goal is to seek that Iran
cannot export one gallon of fuel now
that's absurd it's it's it's just wrong
and it's just they're going to lead to
more trouble and in other countries you
know will be sanctioned as well and if
Russia participates in helping Iran you
know then we've been bold and make these
wild stay
it's that quite frankly we shouldn't and
I'm not sure we could carry out all the
threats anyway now the specter of
Russian meddling came up again and
apparently kept the two from signing a
joint statement how long do you think
that that's going to stay a sticking
point between the two countries I think
for a long time I don't think they're
going to magically come to their senses
and and that we change our policy where
we're very very much engaged as
intervention in interventionist and then
we have the issue of NATO moving
eastward and and not falling through our
promises of keeping NATO away from the
borders of Russia and these things just
add up so I don't expect any any magic
which is very very difficult for some of
us to totally understand because we
don't think our president really at
heart is endorses all these positions
you know of antagonism with Russia and
yet the people he has hired do and I
think that was sort of came up in that
discussion at the president and and
Bolton get along very well and I guess
they do he he hired him but there's been
a lot of us who had always been hopeful
because Trump has said things favorably
and has worked with Russia in the past
and we'd like to just see more of us
here in this country to emphasize that
which means that yes it wouldn't be a
bad idea for Iran to leave Syria
but I think a good deal would be the
American could leave Syria as well and
then mind our own business
so do you feel like the the topic of
Russian meddling often overshadows more
important topics that should be
addressed in these type of meetings
oh yeah I think this whole thing about
Russia meddling I think every country
gets involved to some degree about
what's happening in other countries to
what degree I don't know but I would
consider how much we have done
especially since World War two how many
elections we've been involved in how
many could coos that we have
participated in including Ukraine I
would say in comparison you know this
current Russia gate you know event going
on right now that is that is just
miniscule as far as I'm concerned I
think people with the discipline it way
out of proportion
and it's a distraction from some of the
more important issues but it certainly
is there
I think it's been I think it's been
really stimulated by our political
system here that's surprised and shocked
everybody that a guy like Trump won and
beat the insider and beat the pic jozin
person that was Clinton and they can't
get over this they're hysterical about
it and they even even now they take a
position which they generally agreed
with Liberal Democrats used to be more
on the side of libertarians about
non-interventional but now they're
obsessed with this they're obsessed with
the fact that Trump won they're gonna do
anything to try to get rid of him and I
think in a way Trump may be in a box
because he you know might have a
different position as I suggest at the
same time it's really hard for him to
placate both sides and I think that's
impossible
and that's why I've always taken the
position that you take the position of
what a nation that believes in Liberty I
should do and practice that and and get
along and talk with and trade with as
many people as you can I think that is
what leads to peace and prosperity which
is the goal of my foundation peace and
prosperity is done by talking to people
and diplomacy and trading with people
not threatening people and spending
hundreds of billions of dollars on
weapons that we don't even need and if
you compare what we spend and compared
to what the rest of the world is
spending we're wasting a lot of money
and some day we're gonna have to pay for
it and then I'm going to have my
we're gonna have to back off for
financial reasons just as the Soviet
system had to back away because it just
couldn't afford it
Bolton reacted to one question of a
reporter asking whether or not he
thought that the president was a
security risk by dismissing it and
saying you know have a little faith in
the American people who elected him
president why do you think the media
continues to zero in on those types of
questions and those alone more or less
well yeah I now know who was bullying I
believe that said this trusted in
American people what he's talking about
is trusting what he says but what the
what the neoconservatives say isn't what
the the American people voted for they
voted for Trump who was an independent
populist and a non interventionist to a
large degree and that's why he even got
libertarian votes so that's where the
disconnect is that's where it's real
hard to figure out what's happening
what's going on but the the this
statement by Bolton that the American
people know it's actually what they want
and he's speaking for the American
people will tell you well I know a lot
of American people that aren't very
happy with the neoconservatives and I
think they're on the defensive and it's
a mixture neoconservatives infiltrate
both parties and therefore sometimes you
know what the Democrats do and the
Republicans do behind the scene and that
is to maintain the Empire that's the
goal of the political system that we
have and this other stuff is just
distraction it's distraction on who has
the power
who has the purse strings who makes the
decision and that is very very important
and these fights are real but when it
comes down to it you know they they they
don't have any major just a disagreement
on deficit financing central banking and
the welfare state and all these issues
and matter of fact there's a very little
discussion real discussion on whether or
not we should practice intervention is
Imola Burt Ariens we don't believe in
intervention ISM of our C's what we want
to do is we want to be engaged overseas
but we want to be engaged in friendly
pursuit of Commerce
former US congressman dr. Ron Paul thank
you for your time and your comments
you